good morning everyone if I could ask you
to take your seats and we'll get
underway great to see you this morning
on behalf of the Canadian Institute for
Advanced Research I'd like to welcome
you all to today's symposium social
identity the creative power of groups to
improve community well-being it's nice
to see some familiar faces in the room
and particularly from our last visit to
Edmonton as part of the University of
Alberta's festival of ideas with ACF our
senior fellow who is part of the same
research program as the researchers we
will hear from today senior fellow Eldar
shafir and I'd also like to welcome all
of those of you who are joining us by
webcast and those of you who have
travelled to be with us today in the
room for those of you who are new to see
far let me take one minute to introduce
our Institute for over 32 years see far
has been building global research
networks that bring together outstanding
researchers from across Canada and
around the world to address important
questions and challenges about half of
our researchers come from across Canada
including a leading institutions here in
Alberta the University of Alberta
lethbridge and Calgary and the remainder
come from institutions in over 16
countries around the world and we're
delighted to have two of our fellows
from Australia here with us this morning
our research aims to improve human
health transform technology build
stronger societies and lead to a
sustainable earth and all of our
programs ask important fundamental and
we believe world-changing questions
recently see far has made a new
commitment to ensure that the insights
and research findings that are
developing through our programs make
their way to the people like the people
in this room today who are best
positioned to act upon those insights
and it is this new effort that brings us
here this morning so today we are
launching what we're calling
changemakers a national dialogue
bringing together research fellows with
leaders from business
the not-for-profit and public sectors
our hope is to inspire new ways of
thinking and acting in an environment
that is conducive to catalyzing new
ideas networking and sharing ways to
move forward around complex issues so
this morning you're going to hear from
three CFR fellows who will share info
insights from their research into social
identity they are part of a program that
has gained worldwide attention for
showing how civic engagement strong
social connections good health high
quality governments are greater
determinants of a society's well-being
than its economic wealth and most
important they are here to have a
conversation with three community
leaders and with all of you to see how
together we can bring about positive
social change so I'd like to thank our
see far fellows and our community
leaders for being with us this morning
and I'd also like to thank our many
supporters see far as generously
supported by the government of Alberta
Canada British Columbia Ontario and
Quebec and we have many Canadian and
international partners as well as
foundations corporations and individuals
and our event today has been generously
supported by the RBC foundation and
crabtree foundation and as well as our
event partner the Alberta Center for
Child family and community research
without them the discussions today would
not have been possible so I'm going to
ask that you please watch for the next
symposium in the series which will be
held in Vancouver in the spring and
we've been fortunate to be talking with
the bc ministry of social development
and social innovation and the bc
partners for social impact and then
we're planning a third event in Toronto
with the United Way Toronto and all of
those will be webcast and more details
are to come so as you can hear we do
feel very fortunate as we take on this
new effort in this new initiative to
find partners who are leaders in the
social innovation community across
Canada and really no more fortunate than
here in Edmonton where we have partnered
with the over to Center and I'm very
happy to
the podium over to Robin blackadder
president and CEO of the Alberta Center
and Robin and the Alberta sent her team
Cathy Scott Amy castor and Terry Hanson
have been instrumental in helping t'nuk
to connect see far to you and to the
community of Edmonton and in making
today happen so Robin please join me
Thank You Rebecca thank you everyone
good morning good morning to those of
you on the webcast as she as Rebecca
mentioned we at the center are thrilled
to partner with CFR k Institute for
Advanced Research who are well known
worldwide with the innovation and the
work that they've done this was a great
privilege for us to be involved today
and and just I hope this is the
beginning of a relationship and I was
just saying as a sidebar comment what a
good way to test a new relationship is
organized an event together where one
group is a remote and the other one is
local most of our role of course was to
try to ensure that we had the local
logistics in place including folks that
are have been invited the web casting
but also importantly to match up with
the community leaders that we have here
today it was that was not hard having
said that because there's so many
community leaders that we could have
chosen but we're very excited to have
those though who agreed right away and
very very very responsive in the short
sort of time that we gave them to to
organize this this event so for us it's
important as well the community leaders
have that opportunity to talk about the
real world what's been going on with in
Alberta with with the social context and
so very excited about that opportunity
to bring together the research and the
fellow fellows today to have that
conversation we are very excited about
the response to the invitations as well
we have quite a few people on webcast
and many of you in the room quite a
diverse group indeed we have individuals
from academic institutions government
not-for-profit organizations community
agencies and other corporations
businesses and and this is an
opportunity for us to put into action
what we have always said is important is
to bring these diverse voices
perspectives together to share that
knowledge also in the room I wanted to
make special note of the fact that we
have a member of our Board of Directors
Bev Brennan with us today and her
husband John and we very much appreciate
her support and our board as well in
terms of supporting us in moving towards
innovative approaches such as this and
also wanted to encourage those of you on
the webcast there are ways of being able
to have conversations with us I know
it's kind of difficult when you're your
remote but we do have the technology
chat rooms at the bottom of your screen
you can add your comments and then
there's also an opportunity to provide
questions to the speakers when I first
learned of this event I actually was
meeting with Rebecca at the alberta
family wellness a accelerating
innovation symposium in in the fall and
I was immediately excited and jumped
right in with both feet offered to help
and to join and so for those of us those
of you are not familiar with the center
we have been working on developing an
approach it's very collaborative such as
this working with multiple partners
stakeholders across various sectors and
disciplines and our aim is to develop
capacity knowledge skill in both the
researchers policymakers communities of
families that we connect with and we
broke her we're very privileged
privileged to have the great support of
Alberta Human Services a majority of our
funding comes from that department but
we work very collaboratively with other
government departments we have five
research themes early childhood
development middle childhood and youth
bell being family capacity building
community capacity building and tracking
long-term outcomes and we've been very
fortunate to in terms of the tracking
long-term outcomes in terms of
government services we've been fortunate
to have the opportunity to work in
collaboration with the ministries of
health education advanced Ted and
innovation justice Aboriginal relations
and human services to develop the Child
and Youth data lab and some of the folks
from that initiative are here today we
are working on a longitudinal study that
will be tracking data linked data across
those ministries and we are also very
interested in sharing with you and
having more sessions of discussion
around how that data might inform some
of the research underway I also notice
the number of you may have an intro
stin in housing and homelessness and we
have been in a partnership with the
Alberta interagency Council on
homelessness and housing and it recently
developed a research strategy very
exciting opportunity and we have tried
to link that the best as we can to the
ten-year plan to end homelessness the
unique needs of vulnerable populations
are very important to the center and
today's event is is totally in line with
what we're thrilled you to be part of a
very excited that CFR wanted to open up
their first of the series in in Alberta
in Edmonton in particular I'm looking
forward to the presentations the
participation encourage all of you
webcast are in the room to to get right
into the conversations to build on the
knowledge you already have and bring in
the new evidence and research that we
hear and so now I'm going to ask our
facilitator for the day Tara Hanson to
to come up and talk about a few things
that we need to in terms of facilitation
Tara is the executive director of
business of strategic partnerships for
the center she has a very strong
experience with developing and
leadership developing many of our
strategies actually including the homie
at host housing and homelessness
research strategy has had quite a focus
on child and youth mental health fetal
alcohol spectrum disorder she supports
our Aboriginal Advisory Committee very
interested in the concept and the
processes that blend Western Approaches
and traditional Aboriginal knowledge
research and has been building her skill
and facilitation and MC over the last
while and so we are in very good hands
I'm sure